Being black, isn't a get out of jail card as Candace Owens, as Larry elder,
as Thomas soul. Yeah. These people are, you know, uh, uh, Shelby Steele.
Those people are not their persona non grata on, on, uh,
on as Condoleezza rice who wasn't allowed to speak.
I think it was land concert, pianist, smart woman,
but you're not on that side. So those people are afraid.
They're afraid of true scholarship of nuance and of,
of deep thinking.
[Inaudible].
I think it was another guy who was maybe VOC club smell.
I can't remember what he said. Most of these people who are driving this debate,
who are coming up with these terms, like white privilege,
like systematic racism and stuff like that, um, are at the bottom of a well,
and they're looking up at their sliver of the sky and all they can see is that
sliver of the sky, there,
isn't a comprehensive understanding of the world when you live in the real world
and you have to make a restaurant work. When you have to manage a restaurant,
when you get down to the level of detail,
nobody is talking about your gender or your sex.
We've got to get the food to the customers, man.
And we've got to stay in business, which means I don't have time for that.
I have time for bottom line stuff. And I, and I got my kids and I got,
I gotta make my relationship work. And I got up and I got this pain here.
So I'm nervous about that. That's what it is to be a human being. Yeah.
So a lot of this stuff, when you say getting in trouble for what you said,
it's not real, there's a lot of chatter and a lot of white noise,
but you can ignore it. Your job is to, to stay honest and, and,
and be in the business of original self-expression and keep doing it because
it's needed. And it's water. Bill Burr will say that bill burrow would be like,
he says crazy things on stage. And people are like, Oh, I mean,
I've seen people go our deal out of, if you don't say that. And I said to bill,
I go, you're so gutsy. I mean, he goes, no, not eight people on Twitter.
Hate me, everybody else gets it. And he's right.
Right. They'll call them racist. And then it's like, yeah,
my wife happens to be black, right? Not that that.
That's not a get out of jail card. It's not anymore being black.
Isn't a get out of jail card. Ask Candace Owens, ask Larry elder as Thomas soul.
These people are, you know, uh, uh, Shelby Steele.
Those people are not their persona non grata on, on, uh, on,
on you as Condoleeza rice who wasn't allowed to speak.
I think it was land concert, canister, smart woman,
but you're not on that side. So those people are afraid.
They're afraid of true scholarship of nuance and
of deep thinking. And it requires that.
What about the regular people though,
not the comics that are supposed to be doing this and the artists that are
supposed to be expressing themselves. Cause that's,
that's the big one I get now,
like the amount of mail I get every day from people that are just like,
I have to be anonymous on Twitter. I can't post on Facebook anymore.
All of that stuff because their job is not expression and they're afraid they're
going to lose their job if they can.
And that's, what's so disheartening that corporations,
if you work for a large corporation, they don't care.
They're about their bottom line. You really think,
and it's not that they're racist or anything. Do you really think that, uh,
because Adidas or Nike or Netflix, whoever stands against racism,
do you stand against racism guys? Da, da. That's awesome.
If you can go back and stop slavery, would you? Wow.
You're so noble and thanks for posting that black square because that's what a
single mom in the hood needs from you,
but she must be breathing a breath of fresh air as she's trying to raise three
kids. That must be fantastic.
And our other kids just got picked up on a marijuana bid and is looking at
getting stuck in the system that he can't get out.
But thanks for your black square. And thank you,
Hollywood actors for taking responsibility. I appreciate that.
Cause you guys are making such a difference. It's embarrassing.
It's embarrassing. And thank you.
Thank you for repeating the phrase that was given to you by someone you don't
know, like systematic racism and white privilege, it sounds good.
It makes you feel emotionally cathartic. I suppose.
What are you actually doing? Where were you?
When a hundred black people were shot in Chicago, uh,
over father's day weekend, five of them, children who were killed.
Where were you? Why are you not in the street? They're my friends,
but you're not because you're too busy because at the end of the day,
you can't be, unfortunately, sometimes things are bigger than you are.
And so all you can do is, is reach out like a spastic and kind of say,
I let me tweet something. I'm against racism.
I'm for peace and harmony. You're for peace and harmony.
I'm for war and chaos. Dude, I can't believe that.
But your bumper sticker and that thing you put up in your store,
it really has changed my mind. So I just see a bunch of 'em.
It's like watching a bunch of people on,
on stationary bicycles trying to get somewhere. And I it's, it's embarrass.
There's a guy that's about five houses over.
I will walk out with you after this and show you.
Who's got the Bernie bumper sticker and you know, co-exist and the whole thing.
And he has literally the biggest fence in the neighborhood.
Not only does he have a fence in front of his house,
his door has a fence in front of it. I've never even seen this before.
I'm sure they have more of them in Beverly Hills, but like, uh, you know,
his front door, extra fence right there. And it's like, Oh,
well you got all the bumper stickers. Right?
Look, I've never been a fan of Donald Trump. I don't like his personality.
I don't think he's an effective leader. I have a lot of criticisms.
I did not vote for him. Um, I'm not a fan. Never have been.
Did you vote for Hillary? I did vote for Hillary and I don't like Hillary.
I didn't know what to do. I couldn't vote for that guy. I just, he just,
and especially in the beginning when he was like, you know, if, if I have,
I want a ban on Muslims, I want to build a wall.
It just all sounded on American. But my biggest criticism of Trump is that he's,
he's a Trumpist. Yeah. I mean, you know, if I were debating Trump, I'd be like,
you care about Trump. You don't about the country. So I have my, my criticisms,
but what's interesting about the sort of, and I was a critic of it.
I don't like the idea of building a wall.
There's gotta be a smarter way to do this. I mean, you know, I, I just, it just,
it just sounded terrible. So, but,
but what's interesting about the most vocal,
the people that are really against the wall and things is the people that are
doing that live behind very expensive walls. Try getting in,
try and getting over the wall. That is Harvard, the wall that is Yale,
the wall that is Princeton, the wall that is wetland,
the wall that is Williams Collins. Oh, well, forget that.
Forget that.
Isn't she responsible for the Tenderloin and isn't that her district in, in, uh,
or was that Maxine waters? The late Maxine? I'm not sure. Oh, vaccine is here.
Yeah. That's Nancy. Yeah. So I mean,
of course people live behind very expensive walls.
I can't afford those walls and I don't have the grades. So,
but why is it people can't connect those two things? Well,
here's another thing that I, that I thought of it.
I thought Kansas Owens was w had said in,
because what I've been doing lately is I'm on YouTube.
And I watched debates between black conservatives and black liberals.
And I get a lot from both sides. Yeah. I love I'm not, I'm not, you know,
it's very interesting. I'm I'm the guy who has been,
my dad had me reading Thomas. So a long time ago, you know, this stuff. But,
but what what's, what's interesting is that she said, look,
if black lives really matter and you, you are worried about black,
the black sort of, uh, vote and the black, you know, political influence,
which is what it comes down to, especially in local politics,
you better get serious about criminalizing the border.
Because if you have unchecked immigration from South of the border,
the Latino vote, God bless him,
is going to render your vote as an African-American obsolete.
You can say whatever you want,
but when it comes down to getting votes,
politicians are going to be able to skip over your districts.
It's not going to matter in five years. And I, I kinda, I went, Ooh,
wow, Oh, that's a, that's a contradict. That's a real, that,
that puts the left in, in a real predicament here.
It really does because now you've got to get very serious about, uh,
immigration, maybe even draconian hard, terrible,
terrible problem.
When you have children and you have desperate people trying to come over your
border, I don't know the answer. I don't know how to solve that,
but what a dilemma and what a corner they have painted themselves.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about comedy,
instead of the nonstop yelling, you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.